c'est un énième bras de fer au sommet de
l'état entre le président de la
république monsieur k s arrêtait son
premier ministre monsieur hichem meshes
sujet de cette nouvelle confrontation
l'introduction de mille doses de vaccin
sur le territoire tunisien offert par
les émirats arabes unis le président de
la république les aurait mis à la
disposition de la santé militaire sous
pression carthage a confirmé l'arrivée
de ces vaccins une arrivée que le
gouvernement ignore le premier ministre
a demandé l'ouverture immédiate d'une
enquête sur les circonstances de
l'arrivée de ces vaccins leurs
conditions de stockage leur gestion
ainsi que leur distribution
un bras de fer entre les deux hommes
après la une le remaniement ministériel
qu'il y avait ici en tunisie il ya
quelques semaines où onze nouveaux
ministres ont été nommés par le premier
ministre sous pression du parti
islamiste ennahda des mises qui n'ont
pas été validés par le président de la
république et qu'ils jugent certains
comme aux corrompus alors que les
voisins maghrébins tels que l'égypte le
maroc ou l'algérie ont déjà commencé
leur campagne de vaccination la tunisie
est toujours à la traîne
des contrats ont été négociés et signés
notamment avec le groupe pfizer d'autres
de contrat sont encore en négociation
avec le vaccin russe spoutnik v et puis
pékin a fait savoir qu'il pourrait vivre
et plus de cent mille doses à
gratuitement à la tunisie la tunisie qui
étaient à la traîne et qui peine à gérer
cette crise du coronavirus notamment en
termes de vaccination il faut compter 2
133 1277 contamination depuis le début
de cette pandémie pour un total de 8000
à mort sur leur territoire tunis